ladies and gentlemen the most draconian
lockdown we have seen yet
from nbc new york nyc expands vaccine
mandate to whole private sector ups dose
proof to two and adds kids five to
eleven mayor bill de blasio announced
the expansion monday amid yet another
covid surge driving case rates up across
the five boroughs all private sector
workers in new york will be subject to
the mayor's vaccine mandate starting
december 27th affecting 184 000
businesses well vaccine proof for indoor
dining fitness and entertainment will be
required for children ages five to
eleven according to a toughened vaccine
mandate announced by bill de blasio on
monday the current rule will also expand
the required two dose uh required to two
doses instead of proof of only one
as for people age 12 and older are con
as they are concerned the mayor said
that excludes people who are vaccinated
with johnson and johnson's single-dose
shot which is interesting kids aged five
to eleven only need to show proof of one
dose when the requirement for them kicks
in on december 14th considering they
only first became eligible for the
initial dose early in november and must
wait at least 21 days de blasio did late
last week the changes to these policies
blah blah blah and i wonder if they're
going to make the kids present their
identification now what this mandate
means
is that 30 i believe the number is
30.9 percent of new york state residents
will not be able to use these public
accommodations in new york city i don't
know what the full vax rate is for the
city but that's the state and nationwide
this means 40 point i believe what is it
40.1 percent of american citizens will
not be able to go to new york city as
tourists and use any of these public
accommodations so this is
outright setting up restrictions
controls may as well put up borders and
checkpoints around the city because
they're basically saying
a certain segment of the country will
not be welcome in this place and you
know what the people who are not
vaccinated most likely we know this
actually most of them are from the black
community and then i would imagine many
of the others are more likely to be
moderate or conservative those people
will likely leave and new york city will
just become a ridiculous
mess of deep blue progressive leftist
whatever yeah i i think this time it's
going to work though yeah i think this
this
this measure will bring down the cases
in the city and so you know what let's
just give it a couple weeks you and
exactly
are they still vaccinating for the delta
variant
even though now there's a new variant
out i don't think they were ever
actually vaccinating for a specific
variant they were just saying just go
get the vaccine and it's for the
original the og yeah the og we should
call this what this is this is
discrimination this is segregation of
populations this is only going to
further the political divide further
people moving out of new york city and
the mayor really used very interesting
language to to kind of describe what
he's doing he said that this is a quote
preemptive strike which is very fitting
for him to do that because a preemptive
start strike is when you attack people
and kill them preemptively before doing
anything else that was that wasn't my
words that was literally bill de blasio
saying introducing this policy saying we
need to do this because of omnicron
omnikron's here we have to do this even
though but all the initial reports are
saying that people who have omnicron are
the people who are vaccinated so or well
i don't know about that but they're
saying it's definitely mild and i think
even fouchy brought that out but but
also he's going to be mandating small
business owners all businesses in new
york are going to have to do this and so
we got this report on the daily mail
these businesses are saying we are going
to lose employees so a battered economy
people are already struggling and bill
de blasio look i said it before i'll say
it again i believe he intentionally is
trying to destroy the city and people
say that's a bold claim tim why would he
do that because the past bill de blasio
said we are going to buy up these
buildings for pennies on the dollar and
convert them to public housing so there
you go there's his motive there's his
intent when you got a guy who's like my
intention
is to buy cheap property that's big and
we can turn into public housing and then
all of a sudden he starts implementing
policy after policy by decree that
destroys property value i'm like what is
this robocop
book what other movies we have the big
bad guy being like i'll destroy property
values and buy it
was not the lego movie also yeah
my question here and and it's it's
it's at the 30 000 foot level
at what point does an elected democrat
say i don't have the authority to do
that right like what he's doing in new
york biden said last week um or maybe
over the weekend i am going to mandate
that the health insurance companies pay
for this new test and the insurance
companies have been like does he have
the authority to do that like it amazes
me that elected democrat leaders there
they never look at an is an issue or a
situation and say oh that's that's above
my authority level everything they want
to do they feel that they have the right
to do you're making me want to run for
office as a democrat yeah because you
know what i would no no not for like any
reason to be like i'm gonna buy
buildings i just feel like um
if you work in the automotive industry
then you have to bring me
uh one of those belgian waffles yes have
you ever had those things that waffles
and dingus in new york those carts that
are all over the place that you know
what speculoos is
no cookie butter
cookie butter it's those biscoff cookies
they pulverize it into a paste okay
smear it on a sugar waffle with whipped
cream and i'd be like oh you got to do
it and then what's going to happen
they're be back i'm not doing that about
it's a mandate it's mended
i mean clearly what they're doing is
unconstitutional and this is already
ruled by the courts numerous times as it
pertains to joe biden now you so so joe
biden's like i hereby decree federal
workers have to do this and then
multiple courts are like no no and the
private sector
lawsuits are already going through and
the republicans are saying they're going
to vote this down through their um
special power that the senate has to
challenge an executive order we know joe
biden is pushing the boundaries we know
that he's crossed the line but bill de
blasio is still doing the same thing so
i'll just put it this way i think you
know what we need we need someone to run
for office as a democrat make all the
promises in the world and then just go
nuts and decree the most ludicrous
things and just see like what sticks
like uh
you gotta bring me uh you gotta tithe to
the to the city hall otherwise you know
we'll uh send the cops and the cops will
do it oh yeah we'll send the cops shut
down your business yeah you could you
could you as the mayor he could probably
just walk up to a business and be like
give me 50 bucks yeah and they'd be like
okay they do it it's called taxes and
it's more than just 50 bucks no but i
mean i mean like he could literally just
be like it's for me i want to i want to
go to a strip club give me the money and
then i do it i'd make everyone wear hats
again
look at those old photos of new york in
the 30s and 40s and everyone's wearing a
hat
i would make everyone in new york has to
wear a hat outside have to wear a hat
perfect yes why not i have the authority
to do whatever i want it is for your own
good and if you can determine any policy
because it's for the good of people
whether it's their health well i think
aesthetic is very very healthy as well
you all think we're joking at home but
they actually
shut down churches
and mosques and synagogues and they went
to the jewish neighborhood and shut down
schools they should they well they they
chained uh parks shut yep so that the
the jewish community couldn't have
access to these things you know if we
have
a a politician who's outright like you
know that uh that what's the amendment
where you're allowed to have to speak
and practice your religion oh that's the
first amendment yeah that one yeah it's
done shut down the churches and then
even the courts were like well we're
going to allow this and then no one did
anything that person will become the new
ceo of twitter yes you know if you have
that philosophy that's how you get uh
that's how you get a promotion
if we're at the point where these
democrats have literally just openly
and assuredly and confidently violated
the constitution and the police said
okay
you know man i'm sorry if i'm a little
pessimistic sometimes but right there no
one where were the people in new york to
be like we're not doing this i mean
there were a lot of people who did but
certainly not enough and it was a year
ago and you can all see the footage
online at new year's eve where de blasio
and his wife danced in times square and
all of new york was shut down they
weren't allowed to go to the times
square there was no ball drop but he was
there with his wife dancing because he
was the mayor and he was allowed and he
wasn't masked and that was a year ago
and we've been through a year of this bs
that we're still playing all of these
games of these lock down and it was a
year ago the french laundry a year ago
nancy pelosi got her hair done
gretchen gretchen whitmer
no progress gretchen whitmer michigan
got her hair done and she also shut down
famously a barber in a small town that
had no coven yeah it's a it's the
perfect example these people are i mean
look de blasio dancing in times square
after he mandated everyone be kicked out
and no one cares no i mean i'm sure i'm
sure a lot of people care but not enough
to be like hey this guy's bad not enough
obama had a huge birthday party which
was supposed to be limited in number and
had hundreds of celebrities coming from
all around the world flying on their
private jets to celebrate this as the
corporate media was literally making
excuses saying that the sophisticated
crowd don't have to follow the specific
rules and regulations that everyone else
does that's pretty much what they're
trying to establish here and they've
been doing it pretty successfully
because when you look at these kind of
decrees and i call them decrees these
mandates these supposed laws they're not
laws they're just literally politicians
saying i'm going to play god for a day
when you look at who these decrees
affect it's small and middle-class
businesses because they can't afford to
now hire a security guard to check
everyone's paper they can't afford to
keep employees on the payroll especially
with the labor shortage that's that's
absolutely eviscerating and destroying
their livelihoods and ability to even
have a business who can be okay with
these businesses with these regulations
with these rules with these decrees
amazon walmart cvs dwayne reed they
could afford a loss here as everyone
else gets eviscerated so this is not
only perpetuating the larger transfer of
wealth and recorded human history this
is also accelerating the political
segregation that's forcing a lot of
people in new york city i used to live
in new york city before covet to move
out and say you know what i'm going to
vote with my dollar i'm going to vote
with my feet i'm going to go to new
hampshire i'm going to go to new west
virginia i'm gonna go to florida i'm
gonna go somewhere where i'm respected
where i have freedom where i have
liberty where i have sovereignty where i
am a human being and i could actually
live my life without a jack boot thug
officer looking over my shoulder
demanding my paperwork identification
with every little thing i do what's
happening in europe right now people are
having dinners police officers coming
over them saying give me your paperwork
right now or we're going to punish you
are we going to steal more money from
you or we're going to beat the crap out
of you or we're going to put you in jail
is absolutely insane and it's it's a
violation of human rights i would argue
it's actually a bit worse in new york
city because the people who are
enforcing this are the citizens
you know in in you looked at germany you
guys see that that video of the germans
during the military
march and they're all kind of the
torches
yeah at the same time this story comes
out where germany is marching with
torches there's a story out of germany
where it's like far right marches with
torches and are condemned for like for
using them it's like sure okay whatever
but in new york you are you look to
germany and you look to austria and you
know who the nazis are you see the video
out of austria where the cops walk up to
a random guy in the mall and they're
like give us your papers and he pulls
out his papers but in new york it's the
people themselves and this is one of the
clev is a very clever thing done by the
democratic establishment and the people
in new york that they're like we're
we're having this and our enforcers will
be you you snitching on your neighbor so
when you walk into the restaurant it's
the people who work there say no no you
have to do this otherwise we'll get in
trouble yeah so
it's not the police
i mean there are many police but it's
regular people and so when i was talking
about this many times i'm like they're
the nazis
the people the small business owners
these people who are willing to sell out
all of their values and fall in line for
draconian unconstitutional edict from an
executive
that's the problem it's the banality of
evil them just being like it's mundane
it's normal i must ask a five-year-old
for his id otherwise he can't come in
this hungry man i'm sorry you don't get
access to public accommodations because
of your medical condition or otherwise
have a nice day yeah you know what's
fascinating is where new york is
protecting the integrity of their health
care system by mandating these
uh um requirements and the
identification that you are compliant
with the requirement
but when it comes to the integrity of
their elections if you proposed an id
system they would oh it's laughable
absolutely a five-year-old has to have
his id now what five-year-old has an
idea exactly exactly what five-year-old
has a driver's license what id do you
have for a five-year-old exactly and
quite frankly if i had a five-year-old
they were like we want to take his
picture for an idea i'd be like listen
creepy jeffrey epstein person i don't
know who you are taking a photo of my
five-year-old but we don't he doesn't
need a five-day
an id you get
they'll probably say no no that's crazy
you don't need an id for this just your
vax card well the vax card is
effectively a form of identification but
they've always said that but no no every
place in new york city that does these
and they're becoming more rarer by the
day you need to show your identification
with your vast cards so that people
could validate that it's your tax card
how else can you validate that someone's
fax card if you don't have a proper form
of identification you've mentioned small
businesses in new york and i'm born and
raised in new york city and my whole
family is basically still in new york
city and you you talk about living there
like you go to a deli or a pizzeria the
guy who owns it makes the pizza does the
cash register
if you have to add on top of his
responsibilities can i see your vax card
before i i just what do you want a slice
slice and a coke 225 let's go next like
yeah yeah you know so now on top of this
i have to also
check your status like i don't have time
to do that i'm trying to run a business
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you